get your passports ready virtual that is
an hour series the new normal the world
from home we're bringing you the world
since travel is so limited this summer
today the Louvre museum in Paris will
reopen to visitors for the first time
since it was shut down because of the
virus ancient landmarks and museums are
also starting to reopen in Italy one of
the countries hit hardest by the
pandemic but visiting these historic
sites will be very different this year
if lives Chris lives say gives us an
inside look at how things have changed
in the city of Florence it's been called
a treasure chest of the Renaissance now
after nearly three months of coronavirus
shut down the effete see in florence has
finally been unlocked visitors get a
quick thermal scan and new rules of the
road about where to walk and stand
standing six feet apart like we're doing
right now we feet see director ICA's MIT
says the pandemic might have changed
museums forever in some ways for the
better it means that people actually
won't just need to look weather coming
close to a masterwork like Botticelli's
Birth of Venus they bump into somebody
else or into somebody else's selfie but
they can really concentrate on the work
of art so you think Botticelli would
approve you certainly would nearby at
the Florence Cathedral social distancing
necklaces are all the buzz in the
Renaissance
it was Brunelleschi's cathedral dome
that was cutting-edge today it's these
but it does allow you to enjoy the art
safely says cathedral museum director
Timothy burden after this traumatic
experience people really need to return
not only to normalcy but took the
nourishment to that beauty and history
can give that said obviously it would be
a cruel joke that the monuments and the
museum became in turn places of
contagion a contagion that so far killed
more than half a million people
worldwide and halted tourism here a gut
punch that speared will cost the Italian
economy thirteen percent of GDP even as
sites reopen international flights
remain largely grounded meaning few can
get here the Colosseum used to count an
average of 16 thousand visitors daily
today only 600 mostly locals in the U
feet see just over two thousand people
came on the first Sunday it reopened
compared to around eight thousand on
many Sundays before the pandemic social
distancing may have its advantages but
for Italy's bottom line it's anything
but springtime
now the effete sea may be reopening but
of course it's still monumentally
difficult just to get to Italy so the
museum has done something for the very
first time in launched its own tik-tok
account posting playful videos of the
artwork set to music the director of the
museum tells me in difficult times like
these it's important to remember to
smile recipients this morning Chris
lives say Florence